Hey Georgia, do you have a sec?
>> Yeah, what's up Anthony?
>> So I heard i could use JavaScript to
make Project Compass more interactive,
but I'm getting confused.
It doesn't look like what I know.
>> Okay,
well let's start with what you do know.
Looks like you wrote this out in Python,
can you explain it to me?
>> Yeah, so
it's just a conditional statement and
if this code after F is True then it
prints that Anthony has been here,
and if it's not true then it
prints Anthony will visit soon.
>> Yeah, so that's exactly right.
The logic for a conditional statement
is the same in JavaScript as well.
As you can see,
you have your conditional statement
here in JavaScript, but there
are a couple things that are different.
You have semi colons at
the end of each code block and
curly brackets between each
conditional statement.
Also, instead of using
the word keyword print,
you would use console.log
to print this code.
>> Okay, so
I see like the logic's the same, but
it's just written a little differently.
>> Exactly and as you get a little
bit more into JavaScript,
you'll start to notice that most of
the logic will be the same as Python.
>> Okay, I'll give it a try.